x-men 2 was once again directed by Bryan
Singer returning from the very
successful x-men as well as the entire
cast and this film follows Wolverine as
he learned more about his past we also
learn a lot more about Jean Grey in this
movie and what she can do in her
abilities as this world has brought
closer and closer to the brink of war
between humanity and mutants and Magneto
and his cronies have to team up with
Professor X and the rest of the x-men
because mutants strong people mutant and
proud I remember going to the theater
for this film so incredibly excited I
actually still have both of my movie
tickets for this movie because I've been
saving my movie tickets since about 2002
when I got really into film I still have
both of my tickets for this film and I
remember seeing it thinking wow that was
actually better than the first one when
the Avengers came out people went nuts
they were like wow look at how this film
balanced so many amazing characters how
everyone was fleshed out nicely and how
much fun it was and I'm like yeah I
agree but did you see x-men 1 and 2 they
did that really well in the early 2000s
an x-men 2 did it even better than the
first one because we get to see more
emotion given to these characters like
for instance Wolverine in particular
learns a lot more about his past because
we're introduced to William Stryker in
this movie played by Brian Cox and we
get to figure out more about how he
became Weapon X initially this film also
finally introduced a theme like a really
good x-men theme by John Othman and it's
a lot of fun for whatever reason three
ditched it and then Days of Future past
rescued it again so it's like can we
please just have an x-men theme and I
choose this one this one should stay I
remember the first time I saw this movie
the scene where I went oh my god this
one is going to be better than the first
is this amazing moment
all right it's just everything it's
everything that moment it's everything
but this movie wisely also understands
the humor in these mutants and their
abilities like when Wolverine has a soda
and it's warm so he hands it to Iceman
and Iceman cools it off for him
little things like that are like my god
that's the kind of stuff you don't think
about it's like wow I'd love to see an
x-men film where everyone's cool and
badass but no I mean Iceman could cool
off a soda pretty nice but just like the
first one this movie also explores the
political implications of humans and
mutants and how they don't get along and
in the first one it was very political
we saw an actual senator trying to pass
this Registration Act but in this one we
see Iceman come home to his family and
we witness him have to explain to his
family that he's a mutant and his mom is
like did you ever try not being a mutant
like no not really how it works on sorry
and it's painful to watch because you
can attribute that to all different
types of discrimination in real life of
really anything that people aren't sure
of that people are afraid of or that
they don't quite understand and x-men
and x-men 2 in particular explore that
beautifully especially with William
Stryker in this film because not only do
we learn about his involvement with
Weapon X as I already said but we
witness him using his own flesh and
blood to manipulate Professor X his son
a mutant and the sequences where he's
manipulating professor X's mind are
really great in particular that scene
where Xavier thinks he's walking and
he's crying and then he quickly turns
around and goes Jackson stop back and
you realize holy shit he's in his mind
right now that scene is awesome let's
talk about Nightcrawler in this movie I
really like him I think it's a good
portrayal of the character he has an
incredibly badass opening scene that's
amazing and still actually holds up
really well because I rewatched this
film last night all the effects in this
movie are still really strong he didn't
annoy me for some people he was sort of
a Jar Jar Binks presence but I don't
know he didn't really get under my skin
I thought it was a really good portrayal
of that character speaking of
ass-kicking blue people the sequence
where mystique takes on strikers guard
then gives them the finger so great and
this is a thing that I really like about
x-men - it takes characters in the first
film you were like that's a bad guy you
know you're a bad villainous character I
don't like you because you're bad
sometimes these villainous characters
can join in with the good guys because
they both have the same goals and that
makes this film a lot more mature than
your average superhero beat'em up movie
and as we get to the big finale
Wolverine vs. Deathstrike was my
favorite x-men fight scene for quite
some time until Wolverine versus Shingen
in the Wolverine which is now currently
my favorite x-men fight scene but
Deathstrike vs. Wolverine I mean this
shit is so fuckin badass it's filmed and
directed with an absurd amount of energy
every shot feels vibrant everything is
moving extremely fast there's no easy
shots in this scene it's all done with
so much vibrance and energy
now there's two specific words in film
and if they're set in the right order
and in just the right way it's perfect
and those two words are holy shit I
won't get too into the finale just in
case you've never seen this movie but
what they did with x-men 2 was
unprecedented at its time because the
first one was really good and a lot of
people really liked it I actually loved
the first x-men and yes I do think X 2
is slightly above I'm going to give it
the same grade though of an a these
first two x-men movies I think are
fantastic and as of right now x2 is
still my favorite x-men movie I like it
just a hair more
then Days of Future past which is also
amazing guys look forward to my review
of x-men The Last Stand coming very soon
and after that a collaboration review
with John Flickinger the flick pick four
origins Wolverine can't wait to talk
about that one guys you are the best
thank you so much as always for watching
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuff mine eyes
[Applause]
[Music]